[Music]
today's session we're gonna learn how
cardinal health moved thousands of vm's
to GCP my name is Joe Timmons and I'm
with the Google cloud professional
services organization I will be joined
today by is eben Shaw an engineer in the
in the Google engineering and a
co-founder of Bell Estrada as well as
Luis virzi the lead cloud engineer from
Cardinal Health from our agenda we're
gonna be diving in first as a baseline
into the cloud migration introduction
and concepts then we're gonna look at
anthos migrate which is a new
announcement that was announced earlier
this week which is the next iteration of
Bell estrada then we're gonna look at
the cardinal health experience and what
they did to migrate thousands of VMs in
a short amount of time and the lessons
learned and what you guys can learn from
that in your organization's and then
finally we're gonna take a look ahead at
the roadmap of our migration tooling so
before we dive in just show a hands how
many of you in the audience are getting
ready to do a large-scale migration to
GCP Wow pretty good how about those of
you that are doing cloud to cloud
migration as well as on-prem into cloud
awesome
well the reason I bring that up first is
I've been in professional services for
hyperscale cloud organizations now for
almost five years and the conversations
that I am having today compared to what
I was having five years ago are an order
of magnitude different from the
perspective of where public cloud is as
a priority for IT four-and-a-half years
ago a public cloud it was all about
experimentation getting your feet wet
trying to understand how to leverage
public cloud fast forward to today it's
all about mission critical workloads
moving entire data centers to the cloud
and how we can do it quickly faster and
efficiently and that's where Val Estrada
comes into play I also want to take a
look beyond my firsthand observations at
this survey this is a recent survey of
IT cloud professionals and they
were asked what are your top IT cloud
initiatives for 2019 the first one not
surprisingly is the things that I got
into the public cloud I want to optimize
their cost and save my organization
money but the other two are very
relevant to today's session the second
being I want to move more workloads
right and the third is I want to more
quickly adopt containers containers are
the new VM and everybody is aware of how
exciting they are and all the benefits
that you get from running gke but let's
imagine that for a second you wanted to
take your first ever trip to Europe
would you just jump on the airplane and
go I don't think so you would do some
research you would buy a travel guide
your cloud migration journey is no
different you want to learn from
professionals who have been there who
have done that who have seen it and
that's where Google cloud professional
services and all of Google is here to
help you with that journey especially
when you see a metric like on this slide
where 94% of respondents to this survey
said that they face some sort of cost
overrun or some sort of timing challenge
with their migration journey some of the
aspects that we like to highlight when
considering your own migration journey
are like at the top here where it says
scale so are you guys going to approach
it from just a few VMs a few workloads
or are you considering an entire data
center move to the public cloud
multi-source so you know where are the
workloads coming from are you looking at
bare metal are you looking at
virtualized in your data center or are
you looking at other clouds potentially
that for whatever reason you want to
move that to GCP the next attribute you
want to consider is complexity of the
workload so is it a multi tier app is it
a monolith you know what is it that
you're wanting to move up into the cloud
and how does that impact your migration
timelines and expertise that you need at
the table to do it successfully and then
finally risk so you know most people
when they want to move VMs to the cloud
they do it in waves so let's imagine on
a Friday night during a change window
you wanted to move some VMs and one of
them doesn't move correctly and gets
hung up do you have a mechanism to roll
that back and not impact your
application owners and not impact your
business right because you want to do
your migration but you also don't want
to do it in a disruptive manner and then
the one thing that's not on this slide I
want to highlight is don't forget about
the people and process expec saz well so
involve your application owners right
make sure that the first time they hear
about your VM migrations is not an email
the week before right you want to
involve them early so that they
understand the value proposition why
you're doing it to make their
applications better their application
development processes better and their
business is more reliable and performant
you guys have probably seen this slide a
lot this week and this is our
methodology for migrations and the
reason we use this a lot is because it
works right we have driven improvement
and this is from being in the field and
learning and seeing multiple
organizations approach public cloud and
it's the best way to approach it so if
one of you called me tomorrow and said
Joe you know I would love your
professional services team to help us
move out of our data center next month I
would start with this exact methodology
I would start with a discovery what do
you have what are the workloads right
what are your applications look like how
interdependent are they on the other
applications next we would look at your
GCP foundations right you have to build
a really solid foundation for the
success of your overall GCP initiative
and from experience I will tell you that
the primary areas that you really want
to focus on around foundations are
security and networking you have to get
your ingress your egress figure it out
correctly and you obviously have to
include your security team to make sure
that you adopt clouding up in a way that
conforms with your organization's
security controls okay so let's let's
you know you got your applications
figure it out you've got your landing
zone in your foundation built now you
need to start migrating workloads and
that's really what today's all session
is all about the tools that we have to
offer you to accelerate that and I'm
going to hold that thought into my next
slide and then finally optimization so
once you get the workloads there into
the public cloud what can you do to make
things better and this isn't always just
about the app you know here at Google we
invented site reliability engineering so
maybe you want to take your
operations team and make them think more
of an a cloud manner versus an on-prem
manner maybe you want to reinvigorate
your CI CD or DevOps processes or even
restart to refactor your applications
into micro services and let's okay let's
double click into migration so what are
some of the methods that you can adopt
when considering how you're gonna
migrate right so the most the two most
common that we see are Rijo stand reap
lat form where we see around 67 T
percent of organizations approaching it
this way and you know this is
traditional lift and shift right and
this is typically the chosen method
because it's all about speed it's all
about I want to get my workloads to the
cloud as quickly as I can and
efficiently as I can and this is the
sweet spot of Bella strata and why so
many organizations use it in their GCP
migrations the second is all about lift
and modernize right so earlier this week
we introduced the next iteration of
Bella strata anthos migrate and to talk
more about that tech and how anthers
migrated works I want to invite my
friend Izzy to the stage Izzy okay thank
you
hello everyone thanks for coming for the
session today thanks Jo so I will talk
in this session about my section about
how anthos migrated actually performs
the migration and what he does and we'll
leave enough time for my partner Louis
to talk about how they actually used
this system in order to migrate
thousands of VMs and we'll focus here on
the kind of anthos migrate just for
terminology sake is actually the broad
name for all replacing the la strada I
might be confusing myself now when I
talk to my it's still used to Villa
strata but Alice Braga refers to both
the ability to move VMs in a lift and
shift as well as the new capability that
was introduced today which I will talk
about more
towards the end of the session in the
world map so how does actually work so
essentially the way that a new smart
grid is deployed is basically a virtual
appliance that you deploy on premises
and from then on there is another set of
appliances this is what you see on the
left hand side and on the right hand
side we automatically deployed in a
scalable fashion a set of two or more
instances that are basically are termed
cloud extension but they are actually
used as a sort of proxy to the on-prem
environment and essentially what we do
is once you set up a VPN and a V PC that
is set up ready to go and migrated scale
so as joe says there is discovery
session that needs to take place early
on and basically it ends up and identify
a set of VMs workloads that need to
migrate as a set into the public cloud
or DCP and this set of workloads can be
either identified interactively through
the vCenter plugin that we provide or
through what we call a round book which
is a utility that does it in a batch
form or even through your own
orchestration tool of your choice would
be ansible
or any other restriction tool that you
have that can be actually using our API
to orchestrate the solution the bottom
line you have a set of workloads that
you want to run and move in scale so all
you do is basically hit what's called
running cloud and when that happens
essentially all the VMS are shut down
gracefully on-premises using our
on-premises Rostron appliance and then
they're actually screamed consistently
into the public cloud and we do it in a
way that in the matter of five to ten
minutes those workloads are up and
running in the cloud now how could that
be
if they have a lot of databases and
stateful data associated with that that
the question that comes up so in an AV
implementation that would not work so
what we do here is actually we implement
it one optimized transport layer that
works in a way that even though the
compute is running in the cloud and the
storage is still remote that performance
is not degraded we use things like
predictive prefetch of workers that need
to come a priori before the users are
using them caching of course
deduplication compression things that
we've been working on for many years to
actually optimize and reduce the impact
of the latency so a lot of monies you
have set of VMs are running boot up
natively in the cloud while the storage
is remote and when you access the
storage or the data you access through
the caching the appliances are in the
cloud and they fetch the data optimally
from the remote storage so that this is
basically brings you a set of VMs that
are operate in the cloud in minutes
write down time for the production
applications is minimal it could be 5 10
minutes and they are up and running
which is very important for validation
and for downtime purposes you can be up
and running now once this is happening
in the background we kick off a
background process that actually starts
to migrate the cold data the data that
is not being accessed right now by the
applications and it was seamlessly
without disrupting the operation of the
overall workers that are already running
once that data completes its migration
we're ready to go to the next stage
which is the kind of conversion into
completely cloud storage but for
everything take the cash out flushing it
and getting out of the data path and
then moving run natively it's
interesting though to know that we have
many customers that are staying in this
stage for a while because an interesting
capability offer is the ability to
actually write back the data that is
being generated in the cloud back to
on-prem why do we do that because we
want to allow customers to rollback if
they need it because for whatever
reasons the workload the network as
expected didn't it performance SLA
s-some some Mis configuration accessing
too much component to zone pram and
latency is a problem etc and we've run
into that but the ability to rollback
instantly gives you the option to move
faster I know that some customers think
car dealers well had like maybe 5% of
the workloads we're all back fixed and
then wrong forward so it's a very
interesting capability however how one
you're ready
to cut the cord so to speak you can
actually do the detached convert to
completely native storage and off you go
so this is kind of at a high level the
way that the system operates and Lewis
will talk more about how this being
operationalized into you know a whole
process in which you decide you know the
experience etc we'll let Lewis elaborate
on that one thing that's really
interesting about this solution and it's
important for you is that is it an
agentless solution so one thing we don't
do we don't install agents on the
workloads right it's all done sort of
under the covers through the hypervisor
access to the storage and what that
means you don't have to worry about
opening firewall rules for those
application work but you don't have to
worry about compatibility with antivirus
and and an interference with workloads
as you know I'm sure enterprise guys
know that you know if you can avoid
agents it's better it also makes a hole
cut over process much more easy and
seamless so that's kind of the solution
in nutshell so let's move forward one of
the things that we invested in is making
it pop it really easy for enterprise
customers to start off and for that we
integrated it very nicely with the
vmware vsphere we have a vCenter plugin
that plugs right into that and give you
the experience that you need you really
if you are a vmware operator you don't
have to do much even about the cloud in
order to start rolling those migrations
you get monitoring logging built
extended here and everything is done
through the via center console both for
operation as well as for monitoring
logging as I said there is if you don't
want to do it you don't have to and you
could still run from a web UI or from
the run book but that's a very
convenient option to start with we also
have a very interesting tool we call
right-sizing recommendation what we
found out is there are a lot of
customers that are worried about cost
right if I move like for like my VMs are
over provisioning on-prem usually
because I don't have to pay for that
Orbitz provision I pay for the hosts
when I move to the cloud I'm going to be
penalized because I'm going to pay for
the instance that I need to pay for
peak capacity in order to make sure that
that performance is as needed that's a
problem but really what happens is that
you can actually with the tool that we
offer you can actually inspect the
actual use of those VMs what are the CPU
and RAM you use usability and utility
and utilization and then with that you
can actually come up with a
recommendation so you see here we
recommend if you are cost optimized you
can actually cut the cost of by five
acts compared to what you would have
done if you just moved a like-for-like
in terms of the size of the instance so
it's another tool in our Arsenal to help
you make the migration ball cost
effective which is something that the
DES customers are always worried about
some additional features are of interest
one thing that we really care about
really is make sure again that the risk
of the migration is reduced so we come
up with came up with this utility called
test lawn which means you can test
before you migrate what does it mean I
can actually take a snapshot of your
VMware environment and use that
consistent snapshot as a way to stream
it to the cloud and see if it works so
you don't disrupt at all the running
applications always read only copy of
the data and you could write it locally
in the cloud and you see if things work
as they should work if they don't
nothing happened you didn't disrupt the
application so that is very powerful
tool that has been used very extensively
by our customers we are also an
automation run book I let probably Luis
talk more about it but it's basically a
way to do migration at scale as you'll
see by Luis presentation you when you
operate it properly you can get into
between 50 and hundred and VMs that are
actually migrated at once and typically
within a week so it could be very very
effective with high throughput we
support things like live site little
bandwidth throttling because sometimes
customers obviously want to
they don't have necessarily access to
the QoS and they need to control that
it's a secure and we have also provide
telemetry very extensive set of counters
for both motoring monitoring and logging
which is by the way now integrate
into google stackdriver which gives you
visibility on performance availability
and so on
in fact this is actually a snapshot of
our telemetry information and I wanted
to go and show you what does it look
like in real world scenario taken from
one of our customers
assuming they went by the methodology
that Joe referred to you do discovery
planning scheduling and at the end of
that period you come up with a set of
workloads that need to migrate as a
whole as a cluster once you do that and
you're ready to kick off the migration
this is using Valastro de you can see
that within literally two hours we have
about eighty s close to a TV ends up
running and GCP this is typically what
we see now the Green Line is the actual
data that count in the background but
it's important to understand realize
that from from the beginning those are
operational right they're running
they're operational and then the data
count maybe a day or two days later
until everything completes the migration
in which case you can detach when you're
ready and move on but if you do it in a
pipeline fashion you can get into a very
very nice cadence of moving you know
again eighty hundred machines within a
one week and this is how for instance
cordial on another customers are able to
move thousands of VMs within relatively
short period of time within less than a
year with using this methodology so just
to wrap up basically if we kind of see
what are the benefits of using the antis
migrate for VA migration is the
following the fact that we can stream
workloads means that you can get quick
validation and reduce downtime and
within minutes you actually get your
systems operated involved by the way
this is websphere WebLogic even s AP so
all the complex multi-tier workloads
that are out there are supported and and
validated with a lot of customers that
have used it in the past so that's then
of one benefit and then I mentioned it's
an agency solution which means
the overhead the labor they need to
invest in order to get that solution
working is dramatically lower it's much
simplice it's very automated all the
transition from moving into on pram into
running in the cloud is completely
automated right injecting drivers that
know how to work with the cloud storage
connecting the network's reduce removing
some agents etcetera cleaning up the
image all this is done automatically and
there means that by certain measures we
compared to traditional replication
solutions with agents it could be like
easily five or to 10x less overhead on
terms of that I mentioned risk
mitigation critically important for
enterprise CIOs they need to make sure
the uptime of their applications and
that's also very important and the two
tools are test before you migrate which
I mean means that you can test
everything before you actually decide to
move your production workloads or all
back if things don't go well in a matter
of minutes so this is also very
important and last but not least the
whole completion of the migration is
about five to six acts compared to other
solutions faster you know as many of you
know once you start on a journey of data
center migration what do you want to
book you want to be getting over with as
soon as possible because maintaining two
infrastructures paying for both dealing
with synchronization impacts is a real
hassle well you'll be asked you know
when are we done what are we done so the
sooner you can get over with the faster
and this is achieved through the you
know all the things that we talked about
it's just a data point here of customer
for us that moves 700 VMs again in six
months and and we have we'll hear more
about from Louis about how they did it
so I think just to wrap up you know
we've developed those best practices
determine you know the that determining
the workloads for migration using
Discovery assessment is really important
I think Louis will reiterate it over
that building the pipeline automated
and really get going so with that I want
to invite Luis and he'll tell you how
actually they use the tool to do it in
large scale come on Luis thank you see
so I want to start off by telling you a
little bit about who is Cardinal health
because a lot of you may not recognize
our company name right we're not we're
not out there we don't do a lot of
marketing but we're we have over 50,000
employees throughout the world we're a
healthcare supplier for the most part
supply chain is the the big part of our
industry we were moving a lot into data
analytics and providing other solutions
to the healthcare market but we're
really about making health care more
efficient providers more effective and
most important patients as healthy as
possible
we're number 14 on the fortune 500 136
billion in annual revenue our two
primary business segments are
pharmaceutical and medical so what was
our main goal for going to the cloud and
really I'm sure everyone in this room
can appreciate that healthcare costs are
a primary concern in many people's minds
right so keeping healthcare costs as low
as humanly possible for the patients we
support cost is a huge factor in our
line of business so in addition to two
costs the ability to move quickly and to
be agile and to be able to respond to
business needs we're huge drivers in our
decision to move to the cloud how can we
accomplish that how can we accomplish
those cost savings we really were out to
eliminate the inefficiencies that come
with managing on-prem infrastructure the
the all the costs that are both visible
and that aren't quite so visible we
looked at how many hours we spent not
just from our infrastructure teams but
our application teams on firmware
upgrades patching updating Hardware
doing tech refresh it was it was
millions of dollars
that that the company was having to
spend to to keep all this infrastructure
up-to-date and to keep it running just
to make some inefficiency examples from
an on-prem type environment hardware
acquisition it could take I'm sure you
all have procurement processes that you
know you have a budget you have to you
know apply apply for funding six months
in advance to your to your budget year
and you you hope that the the twenty
million dollars that every one that is
available in eighty million dollars
worth the funding were requested are you
going to be able to get any of that any
of that funding available those those
kind of things right and months to get
hardware procured to get it deployed and
everyone over purchased because they
didn't know how much they needed they
had to request that funding months or a
year in advance by the time they
actually delivered a solution there was
no money left available to to to build
upon that so they just get as much as
they possibly could to make sure that
they had plenty of room application
teams are slowed down significantly by
unneeded cross-functional needs
we're a very siloed organization if you
needed a system built there was seven
different teams you needed to engage to
get that virtual machine up and running
and there's a lot of time that's lost in
that too so it's not just getting the
amount of Labor that's spent there but
the amount of churn time that you get to
actually spin those systems up and tech
sprawl right all of the extra hardware
that people bought that was taking up
space in our data center it was taking
up electricity and cooling in our data
center people hoarded Hardware right
when they stopped using a system do you
think they told IT they're done using it
no they kept it around they kept it
running because I might need to run that
I might need that for something later we
actually found that throughout our cloud
migration process we decommissioned 20%
of what was in our data center because
it wasn't being used anymore
so that was a huge cost that we've been
patching that we've been doing firmware
upgrades on those systems people
wouldn't share because they'd be
hoarding that to themselves right so
some key objectives that we found for
our transformation we wanted to
kickstart agility in speed
we wanted to reduce our hardware
acquisition burdens we wanted to empower
our application teams we a very quick
example we we when we looked at our
caseload for our server team right and
in the number of cases that came in
sixty percent of the cases that they got
were from a development team saying can
you restart my server and do you think
that got done when they needed it done
or did you think it waited three to five
days for that SLA let IT drive business
not infrastructure we want to be doing
the right thing for the right reasons
reducing unneeded labor and cost and and
also deploy self-service this was key to
us achieving a lot of the efficiencies
that we were looking for is we needed to
enable self-service to our application
teams so about a year into our cloud
migration we decided to to take another
look at what we were doing we had
originally picked another cloud provider
at the time it was the only enterprise
grade cloud around then that cloud
entered the healthcare business surprise
so we it obviously started prompting
some questions and are in our businesses
mind and in our customers mind are we on
the right cloud platform for us so we we
started an RFP we wanted to determine
really which cloud provider was the best
cloud provider not just because of
business drivers but for technological
drivers too right if if that cloud
provider really was the best solution
well we're gonna have to suck it up
because we're gonna have to do business
right if you're gonna if you're gonna
continue being competitive we needed to
be getting into the cloud
but obviously we wanted to see for
ourselves
ultimately GCP was the cloud for us
right the the things that drove this
decision was a centralized organization
a top-level organization or you
Confederate your accounts users have one
place to log into they don't have to
switch roles they don't have to switch
regions they don't have to switch
accounts to try to access their sit
their services or systems individual
projects for application teams really
provide the autonomy we couldn't do
self-service before because we you you
couldn't scale to hundreds of accounts
in that other cloud provider but you
couldn't have 300 application teams each
have their own account it was it was not
scalable so projects really gave that
autonomy to our application teams and
then shared VPC concept really allowed
us to give that autonomy but still put
Enterprise guardrails in place so we
could protect the enterprise we needed
to protect egress we needed to protect
ingress ease of granting access there
are no difficult roles to have to
understand it was much much easier to
deliver self-service to our application
teams so we had a clear winner in all
the areas that we are looking for in
addition to the future technology Google
is a highly innovative and new things
are coming out very very frequently in
the data analytics space everywhere in
machine learning
so in kubernetes these were also
important to us not just for our today's
needs but for tomorrow's needs as well
so if you mentioned building kind of our
agile migration Factory and how we
actually migrate stuff so we chose a
two-week sprint process where within
that first week we would do we would
invest heavily on discovery work and
really understanding what that
application did how it worked what it
communicated with what load balancers
were in front of it what DNS names where
someone may have had a static IP address
that they hid in their configuration
somewhere
and then the the second week we'd we'd
get into migration preparation we'd be
building those automated run books we'd
be preparing scripts for updating DNS
and doing our updating single sign-on
preparing firewall rules etc with the
end of that that cycle being the actual
migration and then application smoke
testing so this was this was very
successful for us it since we were going
in to experience it also gave us the
opportunity to really iterate and
improve upon our processes so keys to
migrations success start small right we
didn't start with our most complex
production applications to migrate into
the cloud we started with the dev
systems the test systems the the very
early dev test systems we did were with
friendly application teams that we knew
you all know the difference between the
friendly application teams and the non
friendly application teams declare small
early victories get comfortable with the
cloud it's new it's a big change for
everyone right so having starting small
really lets you have that opportunity to
understand what you're doing
discover the things the road bumps are
gonna run into and then iterate and
improve on those processes building a
cloud culture is important right the the
most difficult thing about cloud
migration isn't migrating systems the
most difficult thing about cloud
migration is changing the people
changing the processes so we put a lot
of focus on that organizationally to be
able to improve upon that
well ways we kept up the momentum we use
this as an opportunity to train people
on new skills we gamified migrations we
had prizes which application team could
migrate the most systems within a month
which which teams would be first into
their first into production those kind
of things
we gave individual projects a code name
we had a lot of fun we had posters every
sprint in in the first phase of our
project every sprint had a movie had a
movie poster theme to it so we did a lot
of stuff to have fun
we brought lots of food in because
everyone loves food right back to
cost-savings
right I mentioned that is our one of our
primary drivers how did we obtain cost
savings when you talk to people about
the cloud the first impression is oh
that's expensive right our migration of
the cloud we had lean migration teams
that were highly focused on what they
were doing we up leveled our existing IT
staff
it wasn't a you know cleanse out the
whole IT department and bring in new
skills bring in new people it was
bringing in new people that from areas
that would otherwise be impacted right
and when you're going to cloud your
storage team goes away your networking
team reduces a lot your OS teams reduce
your VMware team we brought a lot of
those infrastructure teams into our
migration program got them trained up
and they were some of the people that
were that we're leading our migrate
there are actual migration activities we
right-sized VMs we found a lot of stuff
in our data center where you know this
this this database server it was a
physical database server it had 128
cores and 512 gig and guess what it was
running at 1 or 2% CPU and the database
only had 8 gig of memory that it was
running so there's a lot of stuff over
size because they never knew what they
might need in the future again I
mentioned that we decommissioned about
20% of systems we never had to migrate
them because in talking to the
application teams they weren't really
using them and when they found out you
know we were covering cloud cost year 1
but year 2 they'd have those costs it
made them think twice about about
whether they really needed that system
that they were hoarding anymore
especially when we're giving them the
keys to be able to build new systems as
they needed them so 20% reduction in our
VM footprint that we never had to
migrate
something else that was critical to our
savings that was really a culture change
for our application teams is only power
on your systems when you need them most
application teams especially a lot of
our legacy applications they don't do
frequent releases they're not hammering
away at their at their environment their
lower environments frequently so our
lower environments are powered off 70 80
percent of the time nights weekends
business days when they're not using
them
we put automated processes in place to
be able to let application teams tag
their instance so at the time they
choose every day that system powers off
and gave them the choice of whether it
powers on automatically the next day or
not so definitely powering off your
instances when you don't need them is
key to saving money in the cloud I give
the analogy of always telling my kids to
turn off the lights when they leave the
room do the same thing with your servers
when you leave that when you leave for
the day and you're not using it powered
off if you're gonna be in meetings all
day don't power that server on agility
was also a driver right our time to
cloud dramatically decreased we move
thousands of systems into the cloud
within a couple years and that included
taking about three to four month hiatus
to change our cloud provider a lot of
work went into that just-in-time
infrastructure application teams have
the ability to spin up instances when
they need them spin them down delete
them if they don't need them again they
have self-service no more cumbersome
procurement process we application teams
have a cloud budget and they choose how
to spend that cloud budget if they are
going to exceed that budget and it
happiest happens to to be in the same
bucket as their labor bucket so they
really have the ability to pull to
switch a lot of levers to be able to for
departments to be able to make their
budgets and application teams feel
empowered the application tems feel
empowered so really feel empowered to be
in control of their destiny they can do
what they need done they can
achieve their business goals without
relying on infrastructure teams and
people were convinced people who are
worried about their role are excited
about the new technology and learning
new skills while still at Cardinal
Health app teams who are worried about
the cloud love their newfound
empowerment in agility and compliance
seems worried about regulations now
realize that HIPAA FDA gdpr these are
all easier to achieve in the cloud not
more difficult there's so much more
technology available to you in the cloud
than you could ever build in your own
data center and you will hit speed bumps
don't expect this to be all roses and
cherry on top you know it's not it's
everything's not easy people are going
to have fear uncertainty and doubt you
need to remove that fear uncertainty and
doubt by sharing information being open
and honest with your people
we establish a cloud center of expertise
to really uplift the entire organization
we held training events we partnered
with Google to to bring in experts from
across the field whether that was
kubernetes or infrastructure or machine
learning or data and analytics we really
brought our teams up to up to speed on
current technology and really you need
to energize the base of your of your
teams the from a process perspective
industry validation compliance updating
SOPs it there's a lot of a lot of
process things that come up that you
need to adapt to right and being
flexible and adaptive are important
aspects of moving to the cloud it's not
going to be we joke that you know and
when we we find something that works and
find a standard that hey that's our
standard this month but we don't know
what what's going to come next month
because we don't know what challenges
are gonna be facing us from a technology
perspective shared platforms are
difficult right data shared databases
and I know you shouldn't share databases
but
application teams did it right web
servers that you may have 15 different
applications on those are a little bit
difficult to move all right they take a
little bit more time firewall rules for
north-south communication you need to
understand your firewall rules ingress
and egress proxies for us it was legacy
site minder and and a lot of that a lot
of that configuration wasn't at the top
of everyone's mind because that's been
there and sitting for a while
load balancers can be difficult and
network attached storage don't forget
about that you move your machines guess
what you need to move their network
attached storage with it so
nazan SMB don't forget about those
because that we had some surprises there
lessons learned we went we iterated
right we were continually improving our
process after every sprint making sure
that the roadblocks that we ran into
that we don't run into them again in
parallel discovery don't just try to do
all your discovery upfront and then move
to migration you won't gain the momentum
you also want to make sure that that you
are not that you're not over analyzing
things and not progressing because
you're trying to do too much discovery
although too much describe I will say
too much discovery is a hard thing to
achieve but but don't spend too much
time over analyzing things automate
everything is he talked about run books
we we've gotten to the point towards the
end of our migration here that that when
it comes to migration time it's
literally someone someone pushes a
button and the the migrations occur DNS
has updated the the DNS configuration on
the boxes are updated software is
installed software is uninstalled and
and there's very little human
interaction needed with migrations
because as we ran into things no one
likes to do the same thing more than
once or twice and if you're migrating
thousands of systems you don't want to
do the same thing thousands of time
for sure make a migration checklist so
you don't forget things and batch your
migration waves is he talked about fifty
to a hundred that number really worked
well for us most of our migrations most
of our migration waves were between 50
and 100 systems and that was very
manageable for us it allowed us to get
our scale and our speed but without
having too much that we were overwhelmed
a final note keep it fun and half pizza
right everyone loves pizza
Amazon kind of coined the phrase about
the two pizza team that didn't work for
us
I like two pizzas myself so I be not I
wouldn't get very far by myself but we
we really had a lot of fun we really
worked hard and we ate a lot of food too
so with that I will hand it over to Izzy
to to share the wrote some roadmap items
yeah thanks Luis and his team for being
a great partner for us when they moved
to the first cloud we were still a
start-up and we helped them move to the
first cloud and then we did the second
move with them too the good thing is
that you know the service is free for
people who want to move to GCP the
migration service everything is free as
long as you move to the right cloud I
would have said just just one minute
about what we was announced today and
again by the way Cardinal is one of our
good port design partners on the next
step so while you've seen now the lifter
shift is a very viable possibility for
large-scale migrations we also see more
and more customers asking us hey but you
know once we move to the cloud can we
can get some help in modernizing workers
making them more you know containerized
can we get some the operational
efficiencies of the cloud developer
productivity etc and many of them have
tried or - and again we're not talking
about cloud native but but rather about
existing legacy applications what can be
done there the commercial of the shelf
tools etc software
and when they started getting through
this process manually they find out that
there's a very hard and challenging
process and that let us think about what
can we do to help those customers not
only migrate to the club are also
modernized and I don't have time to
elaborate there are actually multiple
sessions on that are given but just give
you a glimpse of what we've basically
done and that was the essence of the
announcement that was made in the
keynote about Antos migrate which is we
came up with this solution that allows
you essentially relying on the
infrastructure layer that we talked
today for transport and streaming but in
addition to that were able to take
essentially VMs and essentially strip
all the system elements that they take
just user mode applications work or then
essentially convert them into a
kubernetes detach the networking storage
that are that they've been working with
in the operating system kernel etc and
reconnect them into kubernetes or
particularly in gke networking storage
etc and what happens is that out of this
process using streaming but also the
transformation we're now getting really
in a zero touch manner VMs that were
running through the on-prem running as
actual kubernetes are actually gke
containers and getting some of the
benefits out of the door right away for
instance you don't have to deal with
operating system patches or security you
don't have to deal with all the things
that come with with with a you know vm
based like for instance you can get the
benefits of networking security you can
get all the benefits of visibility
monitoring logging all this comes out of
the box without having to deal with
anything and that has been really kind
of a jump now once we do that we can
also add what's called cycle terrace and
extend the capability or augmented by
ritual for instance putting in a sidecar
which gives you a service special
capability visibility network security
all this and this all this is done
without making any
single line of change in the code now
this is our first only you know we'll
call phase one and it gives you the
operational benefits of gke and what we
are working on and will release soon
rather after is the ability also to
leverage the productivity through CI CD
pipelines and that will be done by
actually not only migrating the VMS but
also breaking them down taking the
docker images containers elements out
their artifacts and being able for you
to use image based management in the
right way so this is coming later on
leveraging the tools that we have today
to introspect in kubernetes the
dependencies and use that in order to
actually further break down the monolith
this is something it will come down the
road but we don't have much time for
that I just wanted to give you a glimpse
of that we are actually working with a
number of design partners to further
elaborate and develop the solution one
of them is called in law and the
interesting thing to keep in mind is
that our approach to anthos my grade is
such that we want to meet the customer
where they are what i mean by that is
that you can actually transform VMs to
containers whether your on-premises what
are we in another cloud or whether
you're already in GCP but have not
migrated yet to gk so you can migrate
first and modernize later for instance
Cardinal Health has done thousands of
VMs but they are looking now in further
modernizing and they can do that with
Antos migrated from GCP into GK we can
also will support the ability to move to
GK on pram and then you can from their
own move from GK on pram to GK right and
finally we also support workloads that
are running in any other clouds I mean
AWS and they can move either to GCP or
directly into GK
right so all options are other to give
you the flexibility if you need to
decide whether you want to modernize
first migrant later or vice versa are we
cutting really out of time so we have
one minute for questions so thank you
very much for listening to us okay we're
gonna be here few minutes if someone
wants to come
then have some questions offline but
thank you very much for attending today
[Applause]
[Music]